so let's see if we can solve this
quadratic equation right over here x
squared minus 2x minus 8 is equal to
zero and actually they're cutting down
some trees outside so my apologies if
you hear some some chopping of trees
well i'll try to ignore it myself all
right so back back back back to the the
problem at hand and there's actually
several ways that you could attack this
problem you could just try to factor the
left hand side and go that way but the
way we're going to tackle it is by
completing the square and what does that
mean well that means that i want to
write
i want to write the left hand side of
this equation in into the form
x plus a
squared plus b
and as we'll see if we can write the
left hand in this form then we can
actually solve it in a pretty
straightforward way so let's see if we
could do that let's just remind
ourselves what how we need to rearrange
the left-hand side in order to get to
this form if i were to expand out x plus
a squared let me do that in a different
color so if i were to expand out x plus
a squared that is x squared plus 2 a x
make sure that plus sign you can see
plus 2ax
plus a squared and of course you still
have that plus b there
plus b so let's see if we can write this
in that form
so what i'm going to do this is what you
typically do when you try to complete
the square i'll write the x squared
minus 2x now i'm going to have a little
bit of a gap and i'm going to have
minus 8 and i have another little bit of
a gap and i'm going to say equals 0. so
i just rewrote this equation but i gave
myself some space so i can add or
subtract some things that might make it
a little bit easier to get into this
form
so if we just ma if we just match our
terms x squared
x squared
2 a x
negative 2 x
so if this is 2 a x that means that 2a
is negative 2
2a is equal to negative 2 or a is equal
to negative 1. another way to think
about it your a is going to be half of
your first degree coefficient so the
coefficient on the x term so the
coefficient of the x term is a negative
2 half of that is a negative 1.
and then we want to have
and then
we want to have
an a squared so if a is negative 1 a
squared would be plus one so let's throw
a plus one there
but like we've done said before we can't
just willy-nilly add something on one
side of equation without adding it to
the other or without subtracting it
again on that same side otherwise you're
you're fundamentally changing you're
fundamentally changing the truth of the
equation so if i add one on that side i
either have to add one on the if i add
one on the left side i either have to
add one on the right side to make the
equation still hold true or i could add
one and subtract one
from the left hand side so i'm not
really changing the value of the
left-hand side all i've done is added 1
and subtracted 1 from the left-hand side
now why did i do this again
well now i've been able i haven't
changed its value i just added and
subtracted the same thing but this part
of the left hand side
now matches this pattern right over here
it's x squared
plus 2ax where a is negative 1. so it's
minus 2x plus a squared plus negative 1
squared and then this
this part right over here is the plus b
so we already know that
b is equal to negative 9. negative 8
minus 1 is negative 9 and so that's
going to be our b right over there
and so we can rewrite this as
what i squared off in green that's going
to be x plus a squared
so we could write it as x plus and i
could write
a is negative 1. actually like let me i
could write it like that first
x plus a squared or x plus negative 1
well that's just x minus 1. so i'm just
going to write it as x
minus negative 1 squared and then we
have minus 9
minus 9
is equal to 0
and then i can add 9 to both sides so i
just have this squared expression on the
left hand side so let's do that let me
add 9 to both sides
and what i am going to be left with
so let me just
on the left hand side those cancel out
that's why i added the 9. i'm just going
to be left with the x minus 1
squared it's going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to on this side
let's go 0 plus 9 is 9.
so if x minus 1 let me do that blue
color
so
it's going to be 9. and so if x minus 1
squared is 9. if i have something
squared is equal to 9 that means that
that's something is either going to be
the positive or the negative square root
of 9. so it's going to be positive or
negative 3. so we can say
x minus 1 is equal to positive 3
or
x minus 1 is equal to negative 3. and
you can see that here if x minus 1 is 3
3 squared is 9. if x minus 1 is negative
3 negative 3 squared is 9.
and so here we can just add 1 to both
sides of this equation
add 1 to both sides of this equation
and you get
x is equal to 4
or x is if we add 1 to both sides of
this equation
we get my digital ink is acting up i
don't know all right that we get
x is equal to negative 3 plus 1 is
negative 2. so x could be equal to 4 or
x could be equal to negative 2 and we're
done now some of you might be saying
well why did we go through the trouble
of completing the square i might have
been able to just
factor this and then solve it that way
and and you could have actually for this
particular problem completing the square
is very powerful because you could
actually always apply this and what you
will in the future you will learn the
quadratic formula and the quadratic
formula actually comes directly out of
completing the square in fact when
you're applying the quadratic formula
you're essentially
applying the result of completing the
square so hopefully you found that fun